[Music]
what's the best way to think about the
brain that's insanely complicated
everything in connects to everything
gazillion little sub regions amid all
that complexity there's a broadly sort
of simplifying way to sort of think
about aspects of brain function when it
comes to behavior and this is an idea
put forth by this guy Paul MacLean a
grand Puba on the field conceptually of
thinking in the brain of the brain is
coming in three functional layers the
triune brain and again this is highly
schematic the brain really doesn't come
in three layers but one can think of the
first most the bottom most the most
ancient as being what's often termed the
reptilian brain we're basically the
parts in there we've got the same wiring
isn't a wizard isn't a any ancient
creature it's been there forever ancient
ancient wiring at the base of the brain
most inside and what does that region do
all the regulatory stuff your body
temperature changes it senses it and
causes you to sweat or shivering on
during your blood glucose levels it's
like releasing hormones that are
essential to sort of everyday
shopkeeping it's just you know keeping
regulatory stuff in balance sitting on
top of that is conceptually what could
be termed the limbic system the
emotional part of the brain and this is
very much mammalian specialty wizards
are not well known for their emotional
lives part of the brain having to do
with fear arousal anxiety sexual
longings all those sorts of things very
mammalian you're off there and the
grasslands butting heads with somebody
else with antlers and it's your limbic
system that's heavily involved in that
then sitting on the top is the layer 3
the cortex the cortex spanking-new most
recently evolved part of the brain
everybody's got a little bit of cortex
but it's not so you get two primates
that you've got tons and then apes and
then us so functionally it's very easy
to think of
this simplistic flow of commands layer
to the limbic system can make layer 1
the reptilian brain activate when is
that your heart speeds faster not
because of a regulatory reptilian thing
ooh you've been cut something painful
but Oh an emotional state your
wildebeest and there's some scary
menacing wildebeest threatening you and
your terror on that emotional state
causes your limbic system to activate
the reptilian brain and your heart beats
faster you have a stress response not
because a regulatory change happen in
your body but for an emotional reason
then it's very easy to think of layered
on top this cortical area commanding
your second layer your limbic system to
have an emotional response rather than
something emotional here's a threatening
beast right in front of you something
emotional you see a movie that's
emotionally upsetting see a movie these
are not real characters they're pixels
and it's your cortex that's turning that
abstract cognitive state into an
emotional response likewise your cortex
layer 3 could influence events down and
layer 1 you see something upsetting you
think about something you think about
mortality one of these days my heart is
going to stop beating and your hearts
going to beat faster
you're not bleeding and hypotensive
you're not in some hypo glycogen brain
can make sense of this a purely
cognitive state ooh on the other side of
the planet there are people undergoing
some traumatic event and I feel upset
about it and your reptilian brain
responds so it's very easy given that to
think of a three talks to two talks to
one sort of scenario just as readily
though one talks to two talks to three
what would be a case of that what's your
reptilian brain talking to your cortex
remarkable finding when we're hungry we
make harsher moral judgments about
people's transgressions we're less
charitable we cheat more in economic
games our cortex assessing the effects
of pro-sociality antisocial 'ti and
altruism in its evolution and part of
what it's doing and deciding how it
feels about somebody else's plight is if
your stomach is gurgling if you're
hungry if you're in pain that affects
very cortical judgment type areas layer
one this ancient reptilian brain that
should have nothing to do with how your
cortex works having tons to do with it
or layer to influencing layer through
your limbic system your emotional state
influence your abstract cognitive
processes what's the most obvious
example of it when we're under stress
we're in an emotionally aroused State we
make stupid impulsive decisions that
seem brilliant at the time effective
emotional limbic layer two influencing
how your cortical cortex goes about its
abstractions it's not that abstract it's
embedded in the biology of all these
layers this interaction between these
layers now seems very mechanical process
potentially even unconscious one how do
we consciously have say our cortex
regulate an emotion Olympic two layer
simple think about the most arousing
wonderful thing that ever happened to
you umpteen decades ago and your cortex
is evoke in a memory that's got your
limbic system humming along and some
excited state or think about think
cortically or pull out the memories of
some traumatic event and your limbic
system is responding how about reptilian
level easy to make it get into an
agitated state sit there and think about
think about something incredibly
upsetting think about some memory that
was truly disturbing think about
mortality think about global warming and
your heart speeds up layer three at a
very conscious way has mobilized layer
one plot harder is the inverse you're
sitting there and you suffer from high
blood pressure and either they could
marinate you an antihypertensive drugs
for the rest of your life or an
alternative approach of biofeedback
approaches sit
there and think about the happiest day
of your life think about being in an
open field as beautiful think about your
favorite vacation think about think
about and if it's the right thinking
about suddenly your heart slows down
suddenly your blood pressure goes down
ah the core of biofeedback is figuring
out what sort of conscious states you
can evoke that will affect your
reptilian brain in a direction that's
good for your health
and all you do then is learn how to get
better and better in some stressed
hypertensive circumstance what conscious
active thinking can I mobilize here at
this point that will cause changes in
how my big toes blood flow is working in
a case like that that is very conscious
regulation of more autonomic more
ancient part to your brand
[Music]